[Music]
we all have experienced some level of
stress in our lives whether it's good
stress or bad stress good stress can
help you to meet daily challenges and
accomplish tasks more efficiently what
we want to avoid is chronic stress with
our fast-paced lives and high demands
from our jobs it is reported that seven
out of ten adults experience stress
daily prolonged stress can weaken the
immune system and increase blood
pressure fatigue depression anxiety and
even heart diseases and it's not
possible to avoid stress completely but
we can learn to manage it to live a
happier life here are some ways I've
learned to come my body and mind
deep breathing when you're feeling
stressed the first thing to do is stop
everything and do nothing just close
your eyes and take 10 deep long breaths
this will only take you a minute or less
and you can do it anywhere at any time
deep breathing helps to slow down your
rhythm as it draws more oxygen into your
brain allowing you to calm down and
relax you'll instantly feel better and
it gives you mental clarity start
writing down what you're stressed about
have you noticed that when you're
stressed out you can't think clearly and
everything is just a mess in your head
one of the simplest and most effective
ways is to write down and make a list
oftentimes in our heads it feels like
the problems are endless but when you
write them down you will realize that
you can't cope with them one at a time
this has helped me to be more effective
in my work and actually getting things
done rather than just worrying and doing
nothing reduce caffeine after certain
hours are you one of those people who
needs your daily cup of coffee to be
productive well to some people it can
help them to stay more alert but to
others caffeine is a stimulant that
causes our heart rate to increase
and cause us to become jittery which can
increase your stress levels if you're
trying to reduce your stress levels
should avoid consuming caffeine after
2:00 p.m. this is because caffeine stays
in your body for up to eight hours and
might cause you to have trouble falling
asleep getting sufficient sleep is
crucial to lower stress levels go for
herbal tea instead which has a soothing
and calming effect meditation one of my
morning routines which has helped me
with my anxiety is to practice 10
minutes of meditation everyone can do
this and you don't necessarily need a
specific mantra or to attempt to clear
your mind because just like some of you
the more I try the more I struggle to
quiet my mind just be in the moment
meditation has taught me to take control
of my emotions to manage my anxiety and
to start my day feeling calmer and more
focused just ten minutes every morning
has increased in my performance putting
me in a better mood and making me much
happier you can even add a short prayer
as part of your meditation speak to the
universe tell her how you're feeling and
set your intentions spend time with
nature these days were so engrossed with
our smartphones and laptops not
realizing that stress can be caused by
technology give your brain some downtime
take a moment to unplug and spend time
with nature nature has a healing effect
to the body mind and soul being exposed
to sunlight also increases your brain
production of serotonin also known as
the happy hormone whether it's walking
along the beach or in your neighborhood
park just take a long stroll and observe
everything around you without judging
anything spend time with animals my
favorite way to de-stress is to spend
time with my dogs my dogs keep me happy
and I start my day by taking rusty and
Nala for a walk around my neighborhood
by simply petting a dog it can lower
your blood pressure and heart rate this
has been found to be even more effective
in relieving stress than actually
talking to other people also when you
walk your dogs you're about to go
outdoors
being with nature laughs more do you
remember the last time you had a good
proper laugh if you were to look younger
live longer and be happy love every
single day spending time with my parents
makes me laugh
I don't get to see them often as we live
in different towns so when they're done
for a visit I'll make sure to spend
quality time with them when you're
feeling down do something that makes you
laugh
laughter brings out the most pain
taneous side of you and you feel less
self-conscious one of my ways to wind
down after a long stressful day is to
light up a central candle listen to
music and read or write sweet scents
like lavender and slow music will lower
your heart rate and blood pressure this
sets you up for better sleep and you'll
feel more refreshed in the morning I
will also reflect and write down the
highlights of my day this practice has
taught me to look at the positive side
and give thanks no matter how terrible
or stressful the day might have been get
moving I'm in my happy place when I work
out it's at that space where I'm able to
put everything aside and just fully
focus my attention to my body and
muscles everybody feels good after a
workout session
that's because exercising pumps up your
endorphins the feel-good hormone it
doesn't have to be a long intense
workout even a short workout will do
wonders the goal is to move because
movement in any form can be a stress
reliever the final tip is to watch your
diet we often overlook this because how
can stress be directly linked to food
stress eating on high-calorie or sugary
foods only trick us into thinking we
feel better
in fact these foods can cause our body
to produce even more stress hormones
causing us to want more junk food and be
even more stressed out so check your
diet eat a well-balanced diet because of
that will help you to improve your
digestive system and lower stress
hormones
these are some ways that have helped me
to manage my stress and anxiety what
other methods have you practiced let me
know in the comments below remember most
of your stress comes from the way you
respond not the way life is adjust your
attitude and all the extra stress will
slowly disappear and you'll be happier
don't forget to like this video share
this video on and subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more
nutritional guides fitness tips and
workout videos all the best